this is a production of cornell
university
super all right thanks very much
margaret um it's really nice to be
invited
i'm very much of appreciative um yes
it's about
5 45 here in the evening um so you guys
are just halfway through your day and
i'm just trying to
get away from my emails and everything
so this is actually a really nice thing
to be doing
um so as margaret said i'm at the
university of southampton i've been
there for
about nearly seven years now um
and today i'm going to talk about the
domestication work i've been doing
and this is looking primarily an
eggplant but we do have other projects
looking at brassicas and some other
things
so fingers crossed let me know if the
slides aren't changing or
my camera dies or anything margaret will
do a thumbs up or a thumbs down
um so this is my plan for the talk today
i'm going to talk about why
domestication is interesting why i
personally um get out of bed in the
morning and are super excited by this
and also why eggplant why would we want
to study this
species so i'm going to talk about the
demography of eggplant origins
which is about where it originated how
many times did was the crop domesticated
looking at gene expression divergence
this is using rna-seq in the last few
years
we've done some work looking at
selective sweeps in the genome
and we've been zooming in on one of
these traits as well
trying to get down to some candidate
genes involved in it
um just to quickly go through my the
three main collaborators that i've been
working with this isn't everyone
um but anna page she was a phd student
graduated about
a year ago from my lab jane gibson who
does some bioinformatics she largely
works on
human dna and things like that but she's
done a few clever tricks for me
with the bioinformatics and rachel who
um i was lucky enough to meet just after
she published some work on eggplant
and we struck up some ideas about what
to follow up with
so why would we study domestication and
why would we study
eggplants well domestication from a
a really is i think a really interesting
model to study evolution and it works
really well for a few reasons and these
are just some of the reasons i've
come up with so firstly um
we pretty much know what if we don't
know what the
uh progenitors are at least we can know
that they will be extant
so we're not looking at speciation over
millions of years
where various species have been gone
extinct at any point
we largely know what trade traits were
involved so
um we can zoom in on these rather easily
it tends to be things like shattering
fruit shape fruit size taste colors
things like that um
it's recent and it's rapid so again we
haven't got millions of years
of evolution to try and decipher we've
just got a few thousand years
of very strong selection and in a lot of
cases we have parallel evolution so
um studying one crop you can often
piggyback off some of the
ideas from other crops potentially so
it's really interesting to study whether
parallel parallel evolution has occurred
but at the same time if crop a has
lost the ability to shatter its seeds
maybe crop b has
in the same genes so it's very quick to
zoom in on those
uh potential candidate genes um
of course there is the money side of
things so it's really important to know
where our food comes from
and this isn't about sort of farm to
farm to fork
that sort of thing but more about um
where the species came from
how they originated which traits were
involved and what genes were involved
and when we think about climate change
and food security
we're going to have to get more food
from less land
so if we can know more about the genes
involved in yield
and abiotic and biotic tolerances
and that's exactly what we need at the
moment
so why eggplant well firstly i think
it's just generally a really interesting
crop in and of itself
i've got here on the right a picture of
a wild eggplant and obviously a
domesticated eggplant
the wild eggplant fruits are only a
couple of centimeters in diameter
and you can probably see there that
there's thorns all over there and the
calyx and the stems as well
so it's gone quite a long way in
evolutionary terms to get from the
the small fruited very bitter tasting
wild eggplant to the
um very large purple
much more um mild tasting eggplants that
we would cook ourselves
so i think eggplant is interesting in
and of itself um
but because it's in the solanaceae it's
related to
several other crops we've got tomatoes
tomatoes however you want to do it i
didn't know how i was going to pronounce
it um tomatoes potatoes
peppers chilis and even tobacco as well
as in the same family
and for some of the traits and for some
of the crops there's definite parallels
in evolution
fruit size and fruit color and fruit
shape are some of the obvious ones
but we've also got changes in plant
architecture and things like that
and the tomato research tends to be a
little bit
further ahead the eggplant and that's
largely because more people eat more
tomatoes than they do eggplants
going back to the money side of things
so in eggplant we can piggyback to a
certain degree
on some of the some of the work that's
been done in tomatoes
and just to highlight this parallel
evolution so
i've got here a table from a paper
that's almost 20 years old now doing qtl
mapping in eggplants
and there was some significant crossover
in the qtls found in eggplants
as there was found in tomatoes so um
this is based on the same genomic
position so at the moment we don't know
if the same genes are involved but
there's reasonably good evidence that at
least there's some parallels for things
like
fruit weight fruit shape anthocyanins
and a stripe on some of the tomatoes and
some of the
eggplants as well so it's a really nice
study system for several reasons
so what do we already know so i started
this project in about 2014
and before this there was a bit of
phylogenetic work looking at the origins
of eggplant
and this map on the left shows how the
different
uh taxa and and subspecies however you
want to call it are related to each
other
so in africa we have a range of wild
eggplants and it's thought that there
was um
transport to um sort of china in india
um from the north of the range um in
africa
and this is where the domestication
happens so so that's shown by the yellow
star
and this gave rise to the sort of
primitive um
small fruited eggplants which then went
on to be domesticated into the large
fruited eggplants
but also from these small fruited
eggplants we have got
um regression potentially back into
being
weedy forms so eggplant is
um wild eggplant is often seen as a weed
in farmers fields
and potentially this is actually derived
from the primitive domesticates
as opposed to being undomesticated
true wild eggplant so rachel meyer as i
said before i've had a lot of contact
with her
she and she did a lot of work looking at
domesticated eggplants
and hypothesized more than one origin of
the domesticates
so she found significant differences
between a sort of western and an eastern
group
so separated into india nepal pakistan
versus um thailand burma places like
that
with a potential third origin in um the
philippines or malaysia
in the south east there so um the first
paper that i talked about
it didn't suggest any more than one
origin but the second paper i've just
talked about
potentially two or even three origins so
not only have we got um parallel
domestication of tomatoes and eggplants
but we might have parallel domestication
of different groups of eggplants as well
so why and how have these crops been
domesticated well
i've already said about the fruit size
and that's one of the dead giveaways
that differ
um i've got here a p in the center i've
got a picture of the
um a small part of the plant and we've
got
a lot of spines in the top photo and
this is the wild eggplant of course
it's got these uh one to two centimeter
long spines on the leaves the stems and
the calyx
whereas domesticated plants 99 times out
of 100 they don't have the spines at
all and on the right here i've just got
a zoomed in photo
to show you these spines and so i always
apologize to the undergraduates who are
coming to work with me
if they end up on an eggplant project
because unless they're solely working on
the domesticates
they may well end up with scratches all
down the back of their hands
when they're harvesting moving plants
and things like that
but it's not like every eggplant looks
the same so when you're walking around
the supermarkets
um you're probably going to see purple
eggplants that are about
eight inches long and they'll all fit
through a hole in a machine and
everything and they'll be very very
similar but this is some of the
diversity that you can find in the land
race eggplants
um apart from the couple of red
individuals in the middle these are all
the same species these are all
uh salem melons so they're all the same
species
so we've got massive chain um
differences in sizes
shapes i've got colors um ranging from
almost whitish to green through to
yellow and purples and almost reds
um i've got long thin eggplants short
fat round eggplants
everything in between as well so it's
super diverse compared to
um what a lot of people might expect
from a domesticated
uh species
so what we wanted to know was um using
a more up-to-date techniques we wanted
to re
revisit the multiple domestications
hypotheses
so was there one or more than one
domestication of eggplant
um where did this happen and um to look
into a couple of specific aspects of the
taxonomy as well
so there's two main things i wanted to
investigate so firstly we've got this
um potential for feral eggplants so
are they the weedy eggplants that are
found in farmers field
actually derived from the domesticates
and then they've sort of
um been re-wilded or are they just wild
eggplants
pre-domestication so to speak and
there's also a group of cultivars which
have been
either called sub-species of vigilant or
selena movidurum on their own
and avigirom obviously sort of
egg-shaped and they have fruits they're
about the size of a chicken's egg so
so not very large at all and some
taxonomists have said that this is a
separate species
others have said they're just primitive
domesticates
and others have said that they're
they're a specific group of domesticates
that um humans have selected on since
the domestication of eggplant so we've
got a few hypotheses to test
and we wanted to use um more sort of
genomic scale markers to investigate
this
because the reason the research prior to
this was either looking at
three or four nuclear genes or
chloroplast gene sequences
or they were using aflps and a mixture
of aflps and its sequences
and so what we did is genotyping by
sequencing so as
margaret can attest the genome of
eggplant is pretty big it's not huge but
it's
it's not manageable um when we were
starting up the lab
so um we did genotyping by sequencing of
95 accessions
and this demography work has been
published i've put a link there as well
and we've we tried to get a mixture of
all the different gene pools so we've
got
wild eggplants we've got selenium
avigirum so whether that's primitive or
whether that's derived we wanted to
investigate that
and we looked at land races from
throughout indochina
so almost everywhere where the land
races are grown
um in quite large amounts we looked at
those
we stayed away from um the sort of
highly inbred cultivars
because i i think for a lot of cultivars
there's a reasonable chance of
them being transported all over the
world strange hybrids being produced
that may have
uh different qualities that the breeders
are interested
so there's a good chance that
any gbs data we got from these plants
would just
um it wouldn't necessarily be reliable
as to the origin of that
land race in particular so we stuck to
the land races we didn't look at the
improved varieties
um after doing the gbs we ended up with
nearly 5000
snips we did some phylogenetics and we
looked at the population of structure
population structure as well so again
trying to address these questions about
where and when um or where and how many
times the eggplant was domesticated
and these questions about the taxonomy
as well that were previously
only hypothesized so this is a
phylogenetic tree of the
snip data and i've broken it down into
three red boxes and i'm going to talk
about them separately on the next slides
and on the right we've got structure
plots i'm not going to talk too much
about those
but you can see there does seem to be
population structure being pulled out
and the legends at the bottom but the
legend will be on all the slides
so we've got out groups in black we've
got selenium in sarnam so that's the
wild progenitor
that's in light blue three geographic
groups of cultivars selena melonjana
and purple is the selenium of vigilante
egg-shaped fruits
so looking at the wild so we we pulled
out a reasonable amount of phylogenetic
structure in terms of the wild species
so
in blue we've got selenium and sun and
that's our progenitor species
and then we've got three other species
that came out in monophyletic groups
lichtensteinier linea mining carnam and
the first two are found only in africa
and the third selena mean carnum and
it's
it does get confusing because we've got
an enchantment in insane but they are
clearly different based on their
genetics
but incarname is found in very north
africa moving into the middle east
so this is possibly where the wild
progenitor was actually derived from and
that
seems to match our phylogenetic work
um something to note within in salem
there seems to be two separate groups
um i don't know if you see my mouse but
i'm i'm pointing to it now i've got
margaret nodding so that's fine
so there's sort of two groups these two
accessions are from india
and then these accessions are a mixture
from
um more like thailand
uh trying to think thailand vietnam
philippines and
malaysia so it looks like in the wild
progenitor there's two
quite different genetic groups and it
looks like the domesticated eggplant is
domesticated in the east so
from malaysia thailand vietnam that sort
of area
so then we've got this sort of slightly
messy
group in the phylogeny where well it's
not even a group really
it's the sort of thing that no one likes
to see in a phylogeny because
it's very hard to say what's going on
here but we've called this a gradation
so we're moving from
very wild like genetically and
phenotypically plants
up into the kind of almost looking
domestic type plants
and this is where almost all of the
avidurum falls so all the purple dots
is about uh nine or ten they pretty much
all fall out in this group
so it does suggest that avigiram is a
primitive domestica
however we did some approximate bayesian
computation
so testing different phylogenetic
hypotheses
and it actually looks like this group
they may be um
they may be partly because of gene flow
so
there may be some hybridization going on
these aren't necessarily
just primitive domesticates they seem to
be kind of primitive but with gene flow
um from other domesticates so they're a
bit messy in terms of their genomes
basically
but i think we can safely say they're
not a derived group
like a single derived group from the
domesticates
um and there's a couple of other things
in here we've got things that appear to
be wild and things that appear to be
land races
so there's definitely this gradation
between true wild and
and land race i think in implants um
and because um geographically they do
overlap
i think it's reasonable to expect that
there is some gene flow
and there has been work measuring gene
flow and there are domesticated alleles
found in wild populations in some parts
of india
so certainly based on previous
hypotheses
i don't think we can say this is unusual
it just seems to be that there's some
gene flow messing up
any sort of clear genetic groupings here
but then we move into the domesticated
groups and you'll see there's mainly two
groups within the domesticates
um at the top we've got almost all the
indian accessions
and at the bottom we've got southeast
asia so the mainland south east asia as
well as the
malay peninsula philippines and places
like that
so it does look like a single origin in
or around
malaysia or vietnam or thailand and then
these sort of two genetic groups within
the cultivated
a more western group into india
and pakistan and a more eastern group
where we think the domestication took
place
um just two things to highlight well one
thing to highlight twice i guess
in both of these groups we've got um
plants that look
wild and these are actually these four
accessions are all ones that were called
feral eggplants
so what it does seem to show us
is that these feral weedy eggplants that
are found in farmers field
fields they do seem to be derived from
the domesticates
so i think that kind of answers that
question about where they came from and
whether they are just
true wilds which i'd say don't know
they're not or whether they're derived
from the domesticas
and again we did the abc the approximate
bayesian computation
and again it's uh the most likely origin
of these is through hybridization so
they're potentially domestic as they
have escaped cultivation
and have ended up um hybridizing with
wild egg plants
and ended up with this sort of hybridy
genome
um but largely this tells us that the
ferals they're not
true wilds they do seem to be derived
from the domesticates
or at least a portion of their genomes
seem to be domesticated
so just summing that up so in terms of
the demography and
where and when all these things happened
it looks like we have a single
domestication in southeast asia
selena mobiduram seems to be a primitive
domesticate but there
there is some level of hybridization and
admixture
and some of the um phenotypically wild
eggplants do seem to be derived from the
domesticas
but they may be derived with some
ongoing gene flow as well
so something we also wanted to look at
was genes under selection so
as i said before this is quite often one
of the targets of a domestication
investigation
so to do this we did we did rnac so
when we did the gbs the genotyping by
sequencing
these are random loci from throughout
the genome and i think the chances of
more than a few percent of those ending
up in genes is very slim
so what we wanted to do was actually try
and zoom in on genes that may have been
under selection
so we sequence transcriptomes um which
are generally a lot smaller than a
genome
um not necessarily easier to assemble
but at least
um you know that you're the reads you
get are from coding regions
by and large so for this exam
for this study i'm going to talk about
28 individuals we did sequence some more
but when we sorted out all the
phylogenetic work some of our
individuals seem to be
admixed so we've avoided those in this
in this story but we've still got the
data
and we looked at um the wild eggplant
which is insane
we only ended up sequencing four of
those because some of the wilds ended up
being hybridy
and we tried to ignore those we've got
three of another wild species in carnum
which we think is the progenitor of
incernum
we looked at six of avigirom that's the
one with the egg-shaped fruits
and 15 melange the domesticates we
looked only at land races again
and we looked at leaves because um if
you imagine
comparing the transcriptomes of fruit
you've got very large very small
green yellow red fruits and stuff like
that
whereas if you look at the seedlings and
you look at the leaves they're much more
similar so
what we're not doing is enriching for
things um
that just happen to be because the fruit
is larger for example
and then you just pull out loads of
genes involved in fruit enlargement
which may or may not been under
selection during domestication
so anyway so this is how it's broken
down
so the first thing we did we measured
genetic diversity
um and there's about a 50 percent drop
in diversity during eggplant
domestication so
um well 47 so comparing insane to a
vigiran so this is going from wild to
primitive
we've got about 47 reduction in
nucleotide diversity
and then we've got another small drop as
we get from a vigil
into the domesticates as well
so this fits all our hypotheses about
how domestication works
in that the cultivars or the land races
we're looking at today
tend to have a subset of the genetic
variation present in the wild
and given that we only sampled four in
cyanum and 15
uh domesticas this seems pretty
substantial
drop as well we found
several fixed differences so there are
potential for these genes to be involved
in domestication phenotypes
so about 1400 during domestication
and then a very small number have fixed
differences between a vigilant and the
land races
but if you imagine that there are fixed
differences in alleles at
a gene involved in pathogen resistance
that absolutely makes sense that there
may be different pathogens in the
different environments
or it may be to do with fruit size fruit
shape plant stature things
like that um
so this amount of drop of diversity is
is nothing untoward it actually fits
fairly in the middle of other
other findings so maize and soybean the
genetic bottleneck is probably less than
this but in rice and common bean it's
probably
their bottleneck is probably stronger
than that so eggplant fits in the middle
of all of those crops
we did find um quite low diversity
overall though
so in the world progenitor almost a
quarter of the low cyber monomorphic
but of course we are zooming in on only
coding regions here
so there's no non-coding regions
involved so generally diversity is lower
and we found almost a third of the loci
in the
in the land races were monomorphic as
well
so that does lead us to a slight problem
so
what we wanted to do was look at
dropping nucleotide diversity so
compare the nucleotide diversity for
every locust where we had enough
information
compare the nucleotide diversity in the
wild and the nuclear tyre diversity in
the domesticate
and if we see a significant drop then um
we can presume that this locus was under
selection
the problem is that a third of the loci
are monomorphic in
the domesticals anyway so when we
actually run
tests like this we everything is
monomorphic in
um the domesticates so actually all
we're finding
is the genes that have the highest
variation in the wild
they don't necessarily correspond to
those that have had
the greatest drop in diversity because
they've all got no diversity at all
so we we did follow up on this by doing
some genome-wide work which i'll talk
about
next but because this is transcriptomes
and we sequenced all the plants on the
same day at the same time
they were all grown in the same ways we
could examine
new um expression divergence too
and i'm going to tell you about two
comparisons so comparing the wild to the
land races
and comparing the wild to the primitive
of igerum we've done the the other
other comparisons as well but um i don't
really need to go into all the details
here
so comparison a so this is going from
wild up to all the domesticates
we found almost well over 2000 loci were
differentially expressed and what was
quite interesting was that the majority
of these were either down regulated or
silenced so there wasn't a 50 50 mix of
up and down regulation
they were almost all down regulated
and then we compared when we compared
inside them and avigirum
we had almost a thousand differentially
expressed loci
and again a large number were down
regulated or silenced
so what this makes me think is that if
domestication
involved gene knockouts which is what it
our data seems to suggest for eggplant
this could certainly make things like
neo-domestication
easier because if the easiest way to get
from a small fruit to a large fruit
is to knock out three genes you can pay
someone to run crispr now and knock out
three genes
so potentially domestication of
other crops or improvement of more
primitive crops or um
less well well studied less um less
improved crops
it could be relatively easy i say
relatively easy i mean
it's still crisper it's not going to
work first time etc um
but people have done this so there's
some work here by lemonette al
where they looked at a wild solanaceae
and they knocked out some tomato
domestication genes
but they've also tried to redomesticate
tomato as well
by knocking out domestication genes so
um
it's quite interesting i think that the
majority of genes at least in eggplant
were down regulated or silenced
and with crispr you can go in and just
knock out genes
um essentially as as and when you want
so i think this is quite interesting
with potential for food security and
things like that as well
so we looked at all our differentially
expressed genes
and we measured fst so a measure of
genetic divergence basically relative
genetic divergence
between the different populations and
there's three comparisons shown here
and i've separated them into
differentially expressed which is d e of
course
and not differentially expressed and
you'll see in all of the comparisons
the differentially expressed genes have
a greater relative divergence
between the populations than the
non-differentially expressed genes
so this tells us that there is a
signature of selection at the nucleotide
level
because we've got an increase in
divergence between the two populations
so natural well humans have selected for
possibly an allele that's differentially
expressed and at the same time that's
um increase the amount of nucleotide
diversity between the populations
so selecting on one allele out of the
dozens that might be present
would increase your genetic divergence
as well
so this follows our sort of hypotheses
about
how human selection may be working
and of course we were interested in what
these genes were i've named a few here
but and we ran a go analysis as well
just to see if there was any categories
of genes that came out as differentially
expressed
and we've got some quite interesting go
terms that do fit what we know about
domestication so
we've got terms involved in defense so
this is
largely this was due to biotic defense
but there was some abiotic tolerance in
there as well
we've got jasmonic acid biosynthesis
jasmine jasminic acid being a plant
hormone so it's involved in growth and
things like that
and photoperiodism and flowering and of
course there's a reasonable chance that
domestication involves selection on
flowering because
farmers will want a field of eggplants
that are
flowering and future fruiting at
approximately the same time
rather than what might happen in the
wild and a farmer having to go out and
pick a few eggplants every day for three
or four months
so these go terms do make sense um just
zooming in on a couple of genes
this is a couple to do with uh fungal
resistance and
and that that makes sense because humans
would have probably selected on
resistant genotypes um and there's also
two genes here gigantia and early
flowering three
and they've been shown in arabidopsis to
be involved in photoperiodism and
flowering
and these two genes actually directly
interact at least in
arabidopsis so this this is this is
quite a nice little story that we are
and we're doing a bit more work on this
now trying to get a bit
more information about where and when
these genes are being expressed
and how that differs between a wild and
a domesticated eggplant
i'll just take a breath now
so as i mentioned when we tried to look
at nucleotide diversity on a gene by
gene basis
we've got so many monomorphic loci in
the eggplant
that any tests on a gene by gene basis
were simply
pulling out high diversity in the wild
genes
as opposed to candidate domestication
genes
but during or well towards the end of
anna's phd
um there was a new version of the
eggplant genome came out
so the old version was quite highly
fragmented and we didn't try and do
genome guided transcriptomics but later
on this better
um more contiguous genome was released
so what we did is we mapped the rna-seq
reads to the genome
and we use this to look for not
individual loci that may have been under
selection
but actually chunks of the genome which
contain
multiple loci with a signature of
selection
and we did this by calculating fst which
is what i mentioned on a couple of
slides previously
where it's looking at divergence so high
fst
between a wild and a domesticated
population does suggest
adaptive divergence or the influence of
human selection
and we measured pi as well which is
nucleotide diversity
and we did it over chunks of the genome
of 450 kb
because we think that ld drops off
fairly low
within about 450 kb although we don't
have great data for that at the moment
so
we had to pick a window size and this is
fitted and it was functional kind of
thing
um and just to highlight so this is not
eggplant data this is just what we're
looking for
and so if there's a region of the genome
with this very strong selection and i've
shown it by this red box
we might expect pi to be significantly
lower than the rest of the genome
because we've lost genetic diversity
through a selective sweep
and we might expect fst to be um higher
than the genome average we've
because we've got more differences
between the wild and the domesticated
as expected baseball based on the rest
of the genome
but this is an eggplant data however
this is
so this is all the chromosomes stacked
up from chromosome 1 to 12 going left to
right
alternating between gray and black gray
and black
and i've got fst at the top and
pi at the bottom and pi is actually
getting higher as you go further down
fst obviously getting higher is the
further up so what we're looking for is
regions of high fst and low pi
and i've highlighted three of those
regions that came out which had both a
high
fst and a low pi they're on three
different chromosomes
and each is about four to six megabases
long
and if we look at them we've got um
the the region sizes sorry they're
between about six and eight
megabases long each one has several
hundred genes in of course so
um because we haven't got
transcriptomics from very very large
numbers of plants
um we can't really zoom in on very small
windows
um so we're not saying that there's a
one gene in each of these three loci
um that we're particularly interested in
and we've got over a thousand genes to
follow up which is nearly four percent
of the eggplant genome
so that's quite a lot for us to follow
up on but and i did do some go analysis
and there was an over-representation of
genes involved in
photosynthesis in the biosynthesis of
the photosystems
in chlorophyll and in the chloroplasts
and so this is not the same as we found
with the rnac differential expression
but it does seem to make sense that
humans may have selected on higher
productivity
and chances are that involves some
regulation of photosynthesis
chlorophyll chloroplasts and things like
that
um but this is just based on three
regions of the genome and several
hundred genes so
we've got a bit more to follow up on
before we can say
specifically what genes we think are um
key to the transition from wild to
domesticated
but what we have done is zoomed in on
one particular trait which is this
spininess that i talked about
so on the left here i've got um a wild
and a domesticated eggplant
this isn't the wild the true wild
progenitor this is a special species
called liniana
and at the bottom we've got the leaves
and they're actually switched round so
the domesticated leaf is on the left
with the wild leaf on the right and
the paper i mentioned from 2002 they did
a qtl mapping population crossing these
two
uh these two species and generating an
f2
and they looked at a number of different
traits they looked at fruit size fruit
shape fruit color
they looked at aspects of leaf
morphology sizes
shapes things like that and they did
also look at spininess as well
and as i said before that's one of the
conspicuous differences between
um wild wild eggplants and domesticated
eggplants
and actually the the eggplant is in a
clay called the spiny salinas
so it's not just the wild progenitor
that's spiny
but most of the eggplants in this group
are spiny eggplants
um so anyway so what we wanted to do was
kind of follow up on this and look at in
a bit more detail
um this is the qtl map that we were
working with on the left so it's quite a
large chunk of the genome
and on the right this is just slightly
more updated um
it's looking at the same traits though
and it's looking at
the population grown in different
environments now
but what you'll notice is that all the
different prickles
of the phenotypes that were mentioned a
lot of them stack up in this one region
of chromosome six
so we've got spines on the stem the
leaves the ptos
and the fruit and the flower calyx they
all stack up in one region of the genome
so even though there are smaller qtl all
over the genome there is this one large
one region of the genome that
corresponds to a relatively large amount
of the genetic variation
and we talked to marie christine dornay
who is at inra
in france and she's been selfing this f2
population
to generate reals so what we did is we
got some rails from her
and we got some original um f2s as well
seed from the f2s and we did some
genotyping
and one of the first things we realized
was that
um there's basically a binary switch
between
presence and absence of spines
and it maps to this region of chromosome
six and the other qtl
all correspond to the size of the spines
so you need to have the the wild allele
at this
qtl from eggplant chromosome 6 to have
any spines
and then multiple qtl around the genome
will give rise to larger or smaller
spines
so what we were doing is we wanted to
zoom in on this sort of binary switch
almost
for the presence absence so we started
out with a seven
megabase region which is largely based
on this genetic mapping
and this is where it's used for having
multiple crops because
some of these markers are only found in
tomato but the tomato chromosome 6 and
the eggplant chromosome 6
apart from a region at the top which has
been flipped they're largely co-linear
so we could use data from tomato and the
data from the eggplant genome which was
coming online
while we were doing this so we figured
out this was approximately a seven
megabase window
um we generated 120 plants that
segregated three to one spinach and non
spiny
so as i said before there's it looks
like there's a mendelian locust
controlling presence absence of spines
and then within the spiny plants there's
a gradation from
um very small couple of millimeter
spines
up to the sort of one and a half
centimeter spines that
scratch the skin on the back of your
hand when you get near to them
um so the way what we wanted to do was
zoom in on this seven megabase
region so we generated some
transcriptomes from linear i'm going to
talk about that in a second
and we map those to the eggplant genome
and then we just simply looked for indel
markers
so then i had undergraduates in the lab
who were scoring in dell markers in
these 120 plants
so we had 14 markers in this seven
megabase region
and we've zoomed in on about two
megabases now
um so two megabases is a sizable chunk
it's still got a couple of hundred genes
in it we think
um but we have narrowed it down a bit
um we're only looking at 120 plants
um so i don't think based on those 120
i don't think it's worth us throwing any
more markers at it because we haven't
got enough recombination in that area of
the genome
but what we did do is we collected some
plants that were
well we collected the see the fruit from
some heterozygous plants
and we've got from one of those we've
got about a thousand seed
and from another couple of plants we've
got several hundred seeds so
what we can do now is grow up the large
populations
um as margaret will attest an eggplant
is a pretty sizable plant
and so growing up a thousand plants is
no mean feat
however you can tell whether the plants
are spiny or not spiny
when they're only about um two or three
months old and only
six inches tall so this is something we
we need obviously time and we need
um uh someone to be able to do this but
it is something that we're going to
start next year
i think so as i said we generated linear
transcriptomes and what we did is we did
six transcriptomes
we did three from the spines and three
from the veins because the spines on the
leaves are formed out of the veins
so what we wanted to do was look at
differential expression
between essentially a spine which is an
elongated bit of a vein
and another piece of vein and as i said
we did it for
three three different lineal implants
and
we did differential expression to look
at the genes that might be involved in
this trait
and this is just the sort of typical
plot you see but um
clearly we've got separation of the
three veins
on the right and no sorry the three
veins on the left
and the three spines on the right and
these are all our differentially
expressed genes
and so they fall out in two main
clusters we've got high expression in
the veins low expression in
spines or vice versa so at the moment we
can't really say whether it might be a
knockout
or an upregulation or anything like that
um we found about point six percent of
transcripts for de so quite a small
number which
is easier to work with and about 50 of
these fell
out in this two megabase region so i
think what we secretly wanted was one or
two genes
in that two megabase region to also be
differentially expressed
um sadly we've got about 50 but some of
them we can follow up on and
there's a few interesting interesting
candidates there's genes involved in the
modification of cellulase and of course
you've got cell walls being elongated so
that makes sense
um and other other genes that may or may
not be involved
and then there's a bunch of other genes
as well um
so we're not ready to say we've got one
or even five or even 20 candidates
but we have got enough data that we've
got things to zoom in on
and i think once we grow up our larger
mapping population
um hopefully we can zoom in on a smaller
region of the genome
and then we've got a bit more to sort of
we can bring together our data a bit
better
to compare the differential expression
we can look at um
where they map and ideally you know
finding potentially differentially
expressed genes in this region although
we don't know it's differentially
expressed it might just be a
polymorphism
that um changes the coding sequence
we've we've got no a priory reason to
think it's differential expression
but again it's a different um a
different place to look
um and just recently there was a
selenium linear and genome released
and it's not the most high quality but
um we've mapped it back to the uh the
domesticated eggplant genome
and so we've now very easily we can go
in and design hundreds of molecular
markers
just for this small region uh we just
need time and we need a bit of space to
get on with this
right now um but we're quite happy we're
quite enjoying this
at the moment um i've had various people
working on it and uh
we seem to be getting closer anyway um
so just to sum up i think i'm about
40 40 minutes so that's not bad
so we've got an interesting and a
convoluted domestication of eggplant
we've got post-domestication gene flow
and we do have a lot of overlap between
where these land races are grown
and where the wildland wild eggplants
are found
so it's not unexpected we've got escape
from domestication so we've got
quite an interesting potential
evolutionary story about
d domestication and whether you get
how this kind of reversal of the
domestication syndrome comes about
lots of candidate genes so we've got a
lot to work with
um it's a fun time to be working on
eggplants but at the same time it's
it's this sort of giant excel sheets and
our documents with hundreds of different
uh things in that we need to
uh look at but we do seem to be getting
closer at least to this one trait
um that we're particularly interested in
so that's quite exciting
and we are sort of zooming in on it
right now
so just to acknowledge uh people so anna
was the phd student who did
a lot of the demography jane helped us
out with some of the more tricky
bioinformatics
and rachel she supplied us with some
seed and i think she may have illegally
sent it to us through the post
um but we we grew it and we threw the
plants away we didn't grow in our own
gardens
um i've had a few undergraduates and
masters students working on this
uh too many to name but a lot of those
underground
graduates have been trolling through the
ndlp pcr and stuff
um special thanks to mary christine
dornea inra
because she was she didn't just supply
the seed but
she has been maintaining these
populations um and she's obviously
supplied a lot to margaret as well
so she's still involved and she's still
interested which is great
and i had funding from the university
when i got there i got an annual
adventures grant
and i'd like to thank margaret as well
for the invite it's really
really interesting to talk to you guys
um and thanks cornell as well for
hosting as well um i'd obviously be
happy to take any questions i presume
that's where we're going next is that
right
yes thank you mark for a wonderful
season and thank you to the zoom gods
for
a smooth connection amazing like eight
well
five thousand miles away and nosing zone
problems
great um great so
open it up to questions you can either
type in the chat or
um you can just unmute yourself and ask
your question
i see there is a question here
developmentally how do the spines form
and it's the absence of spines due to a
failure of specification
cool i don't think we know i mean i
think
i think once we get closer to knowing
what the candidate gene might be
or what the sort of presence absence
gene might be i think that's going to
help
they do seem to just grow out of the
veins it's it's hard to say
exactly what tissues or exactly what
cell types are involved
um i think we we need to do a bit of
work on that i have been talking to
people about doing
um electron microscopy of the of the
developing spines
um that was a conversation that started
about a year ago and obviously we all
know what happened about nine months ago
so um that's put on hold for now
i think we we would like to know a bit
more and i think it will help us find
candidate genes as well so if we know
it's
an elongation of the cell wall or if we
know it's a breakdown in some
compound that would normally constrain
the cell wall
we can start zooming in on that whether
it's lignin or something like that
um but developmentally they they don't
seem to be the same as trichomes in
tomatoes which is a bit disappointing
because obviously if it was the same
developmentally
we've got candidate genes we can start
looking at but i don't think
we can do that because they don't seem
to be developmentally the same as a
trichome
um they they're multicellular right
yeah they're multicellular yeah cool
yeah um adrian the
professor who asked the question works
on live cell imaging
um so that would be a great system
um to do live imaging okay yeah so
sounds good jim um a question from jeff
doyle
um are you working on working on more of
the messy
gene flow issues um using network
methods
perhaps yeah we we have actually been
doing that
so we've got at the moment we've got a
project on brassicas and
um the the postdoc who's working on that
um she's now getting very adept at all
these network
type um doing gene-based phylogenies and
putting them together to make networks
and things like that so
yeah we are following up with that
actually um this was published
over a year ago and since then we've got
a lot of the brassica data and
turns out brassica's a real mess as well
so um actually the postdoc's probably
going to apply some of their skills to
this eggplant data
very cool um i have a
question and then hamid has a question
i'll ask him to
unmute himself for his because it's a
two-part um
if he's okay with that but i'll i'll
start um i'm interested in those
um feral uh kind of
weedy species that you identified um
do you think that their like f1 hybrids
are like really close to the
hybridization event and thus
exhibiting hybrid vigor and that kind of
helps them be successful as weedy
species
or is it more of a situation where
they've
kind of um hybridized uh
several generations ago and then um
yeah i i don't think i don't know i i
don't think these are sort of early
generation hybrids that are super
heterotic
and then just manage to live everywhere
um
we did a bit of work which we couldn't
really conclude much from so i'm
hesitant to talk about it too much so
take this off with a pinch of salt but
what we did
is we looked in these feral um we
we had some transcriptomes from the
ferals
and it seems
like a non insignificant proportion
of the loci that are introgressed do
seem to be candidates for being under
selection during domestication so
they have a largely domesticated genome
and the bit that's introgressed
seems to be enriched for genes that may
have been under selection during
domestication
so it may be spiny genes dwarfing genes
small fruit genes that have introgressed
into the um
domesticates um
[Music]
but we've we've got a long way to go
with that so pinch yourself
yeah very cool um are you okay
asking your yes thank you sure uh great
talk mark
thank you thank you mate i have two
questions one is
uh you mentioned that obj has gene flow
with the cultivated plants so i wonder
if you have tested for gene flow with
the wild
ancestor also
yeah let me try and think about that
i think i think it's entirely probable
that that has happened
um i guess that as far as i remember
that wasn't one of our scenarios we
tested though
um yeah i
don't think i don't think we tested that
so
i couldn't really comment on that but i
think there is a chance yeah absolutely
and i was
also wondering whether the fruit
phenotypes are
diverse in objero or
do they all have egg shaped uh no
so they they all well everything that's
called a vigram is based on having these
egg-shaped fruits
so um phenotypically they are all very
similar
there's there's some sort of yellowish
fruits and some
very bright white fruits um but
because there's so much diversity
there's long and short and and fat and
round and everything
and i think everything has just been
named a vigilant that looks about like
that
sure but in our phylogeny um even though
they're all in that gradation i think
there's two of idram
vigilam accessions that are in the
domesticas
so it looks like they may be
independently derived egg-shaped fruit
cultivars um but i think they're found
in very different places in the
phylogeny
and very different from where the other
revision rooms are
great thank you you're welcome and uh we
have one more
question from jim jiminy um given the
presence the absence of
unicorns um jim's wondering
if you might expect something other than
a cell wall candidate
for example a transcription factor or
kinase or other
some other kind of master regulator um
and you know perhaps you could take your
mapping region and compare it to a
non-spiny
relative um like tomato to
narrow yeah um actually so i've got a
phd student starting after christmas who
is going to be
zooming in on this so we're going to use
as much data as we can get
so we've got one of the linearnum
genomes
we've got um we've got all the
transcriptomes that we've generated
we've got a small number of domesticated
genomes and then we've got things like
tomatoes
and even potatoes if we want to go that
far so what we'd like to do
is try and throw together as much data
as possible
and it's interesting you mentioned
kinases because in that region of the
genome there are a few kinases
and i know that kinase is a very broad
topic
or a broad category of genes but it does
seem to be a cluster of kinases
so that might be entirely circumspect
and nothing to do with
spines but it does seem that there is a
cluster of kinases in that
i'm excited to find out
give me a year or two i'm not quite
ready but yeah yeah
great um so if there are no more
questions join me
in thanking mark for a wonderful talk
and um
tgi friday mark you're done with your
day so
thank you well no i've got to talk to
some phd students now apparently in
about
10 minutes is that right oh great yes
okay phd students um
join mark you're not off the hook yet um
it's fine no problem
great thank you so much thank you i've
really enjoyed it
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu